♪♪
>>Tucker: WELL, SEPTEMBER IS RAP
STAR MONTH ONEN THIS SHOW,
APPARENTLY.
LAST WEEK WE TOLD YOU
ALL ABOUT NICK A MINAJ.
TONIGHT AN INTERVIEW
WITH ZUBY, A RAPPER IN
THE UNITED KINGDOM, AND
A VERY INSIGHTFUL
OBSERVER OF AMERICAN
POLITICS.  NOT AT ALL
AFRAID TO SAY WHAT HE
THINKS.  WE'RE Y SAT
DOWN WITH HIM FOR A NEW
EMVOTE OF TUCKER CARLSON
TODAY.  HE TOLD US WHAT
HE THINKS OF THE COVID
MANDATES AND THE STATE
OF OUR RULING CLASS.
IT'S WORTH LISTENING TO.
HERE'S PART OF IT.
>> WHEN YOU'RE IN LONDON, UM, AD
YOU'RE IN GREAT BRITAIN, DOES
ANYBODY EVER SAY YOU KNOW I CANT
BELIEVE WHAT'S GOING ON.
HERE YOU HAVE BORIS JOHNSON, A
SMARTS GUY BUT CAN'T MANAGE HIS
OWN, WE DON'T EVEN KNOW HOW MANY
KIDS HE HAS.
HE'S KIND OF A DISASTER
PERSONALLY TELLING US HOW TO
MANAGE THE INTIMATE DETAILS OF
OUR LIVES.  THAT'S WRONG.
DOES ANYBODY EVER SAY THAT?
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE DO.
>>Tucker: THEY DO INGOOD.
>> THERE IS A RESISTENCE.
I DON'T WANT IT TO SOUND LIKE
EVERY BRITISH PERSON IS A SHEEP
WHO'S JUST WILLING TO COMPLY WIH
WHATEVER DADDY GOVERNMENT SAYS.
IT'S NOT LIKE THAT AT ALL.
I THINK PROPORTIONALLY, THOUGH,
IT'S, IT'S DIFFERENT.
AND ANOTHER THING WITH THE U-S-A
AND AGAIN A LOT OF AMERICANS TAE
ADVANTAGE, A HUGE ADVANTAGE OF
THIS COUNTRY BEYOND ITS SIZE,
GEOGRAPHICAL SCALE AND ITS
POPULATION, IS THAT YOU HAVE
STATES.
RIGHT?
YOU HAVE 50 DIFFERENT OPTIONS
WITHIN YOUR OWN COUNTRY WHERE YU
DON'T LIKE THE WAY THINGS ARE
GOING IN CALIFORNIA, YOU'VE GOT
49 OTHER OPTIONS.
YOU DON'T DON'T LIKE THE WAY
THINGS ARE HERE, YOU CAN MOVE
WITHOUT LEAVING YOUR WHOLE
COUNTRY.  WHEREAS WITH LOTS OF
OTHER COUNTRIES, IF THINGS ARENT
GOING WELL - - THERE'S A KIND OF
POSITION I'VE FOUND MYSELF IN.
I LOVE THE U-K, IT'S A WONDERFUL
COUNTRY IN MANY REGARDS, BUT I
WAS JUST FEEL LOOK LIKE, MAN,
THERE'S, I DON'T REALLY LIKE THE
WAY THIS IS TRENDING, I HAVE A
LOT OF CONCERNS WITH THIS
DIRECTION AND THIS RESPONSE.
WITH ME IT'S LIKE WELL, THERE'S
NOWHERE ELSE TO GO BESIDES
LITERALLY LEAVING THE WHOLE
COUNTRY, WHICH IS BITTERSWEET.
IT'S AN ADVENTURE, BUT I DON'T
LEAK THE FACT THAT I FELT LIKE Y
HAND WAS FORCED.
>>Tucker: YEAH.
THINGS WERE GOING IN SUCH A
DIRECTION WHERE I WAS LIKE YEAH,
MAN, I DON'T, I DON'T KNOW YOU
BE?
AGAIN, I TALK TO PEOPLE WHO LIVE
IN, UM, ALL THE FREEDOM LOVERS
WHO ARE IN THERE IN PLACES LIKE
AUSTRALIA RIGHT NOW, IT'S A BAD
SITUATION.  YOU CAN'T LEAVE THE
COUNTRY.
>>Tucker: YEAH.
>> I MEAN, THAT IN ITSELF, IT'S
ONE THING - -
>>Tucker: YOU CAN'T LEAVE.
>> THEY CAN'T LEAVE THE COUNTRY.
YOU CAN'T COME IN, YOU CAN'T COE
IN.
IT'S GONE BACK TO BEING A PENAL
COLONY.
>>Tucker: WHY IS THAT BETTER
THAN CUBA?
BETTER BEACHES?
THIS IS THE THING AND YOU KNOW
IT'S ALSO BEEN REVEALED THAT A
LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T VALUE LIBERY
AND FREEDOM.
>>Tucker: NO.
PERHAPS IN THE WAY THAT WE
THOUGHT THAT THEY DID OR PEOPLE
CLAIMED TO.
I THINK NOW YOU'RE SEEING THAT,
YEAH, I'VE ALWAYS HAD A SUSPICIN
THAT REALLY PEOPLE VALUE SAFETY
AND SECURITY OR AT LEAST THE
ILLUSION OF IT MORE THAN FREEDOM
AND LIBERTY.
THAT'S REALLY PROVEN TO BE THE
CASE.
EVERYTHING THAT'S GONE ONEN,
EVERY AUTHORITARIANISM OR
OUTRIGHT TYRANNY, THE
JUSTIFICATION IS FOR THE GREATER
GOOD, FOR YOUR HEALTH, FOR YOUR
SAFETY.
THAT'S ALWAYS THE JUSTIFICATION,
EVEN IF THEY'RE CLEARLY, CLEARLY
ALL GOING WAY, WAY, WAY BEYOND
THAT.
>>Tucker: IT'S ALL FROM PEOPLE
ZOO NO DEMONSTRATED RECORD OF
SUCCESS IN THE FIELD THAT
THEY'RE ESPOUSING ON.
>> MMHM.
>>Tucker: JOE BIDEN LAST WEEK
LITERALLY GOT UP THERE AND
LECTURED AMERICAN PARENTS ONEN
HOW TO RAISE THEIR KIDS.  JOE
BIDEN.
HAS NO RIGHT TO LECTURE ANYONE N
HOW TOOTLES IR CHILDREN, ARE YOU
JOKING?
HE SHOULD BE ASHAMED.
BUT IT'S TRUE.
BUT IT'S TRUE ACROSS THE BOARD.
>> YEAH.
>>Tucker: MAYBE PART OF THE
PROBLEM IS JUST INREPRESENT
LEADERS.
>> YEAH - - INEPT LEADER.
>> YEAH, IT'S AWL ALSO EASY TO
ADVOCATE FOR THINGS THAT DON'T
AFFECT YOU.
THIS HAS BEEN ONE OF THE BIGGEST
PROBLEMS ALL THROUGHOUT - -
CERTAINLY IT'S ALWAYS A PROBLEM
BUT OVER THE PAST 18 MONTHS
ESPECIALLY.  WE'VE SEEN THIS,
WE'VE ALL SEEN THE GOVERNORS AND
THE MAYORS, AND PRIME MINISTERS
WHOEVER THEY ARE OUT HAVING THER
PARTIES AND GOING MASKLESS AND
NOT SOCIALLY DISTANCING, AND
VIOLATING ALL THEIR RULES, GOING
ON FOREIGN HOLIDAYS WHILE THEY'E
TELLING THEIR CITIZENS TO STAY T
HOME AND TO WAFER A MASK, AND T,
YOU KNOW, TO DO THIS AND DO THA.
AND THAT, I MEAN, IT'S LIKE
ANIMAL FARM, JUST THAT LEVEL OF
OUTRIGHT HYPOCRISY.
>>Tucker: YES.
>> THAT'S JUST BEEN RAMMED IN
PEOPLES' FACES.
>>Tucker: THAT WENT ON FOR ABOUT